[Music]
in 1958 Rachel Carson received a letter
describing songbirds suddenly dropping
from tree branches the writer blamed
their deaths on a pesticide called DDT
that exterminators had sprayed on a
nearby Marsh the letter was the push
Carson needed to investigate DDT she had
already heard from scientists and
conservationists who were worried that
rampant use of the pesticide posed a
threat to fish birds and possibly humans
she began to make inquiries through
government contacts from her years
working in the United States Bureau of
fisheries she asked what has already
silenced the voices of spring in 1962
Carson published her findings in Silent
Spring her book documented the misuse of
chemicals and their toll on nature and
human health Silent Spring immediately
drew both applause and impassioned
dissent along with vicious personal
attacks on the author how did this
mild-mannered biologist and writer
ignite such controversy Carson began her
career as a hard-working graduate
student balancing her studies in biology
at John Hopkins University with
part-time jobs still she had to leave
school before completing her doctorate
to provide for her ailing father and
sister Carson found part-time work with
the Bureau of fisheries writing for a
radio program on marine biology her
ability to write materials that could
hold the general public's attention
impressed her superiors and in 1936 she
became the second woman to be hired at
the bureau full-time in 1941 she
published the first of three books on
the ocean combining science with lyrical
meditations on underwater worlds these
explorations resonated with a wide
audience
in Silent Spring Carson turned her
attention to the ways human actions
threatened the balance of nature DDT was
originally used during World War two to
shield crops from insects and protect
soldiers from insect borne diseases
after the war it was routinely sprayed
in wide swaths to fight pests often with
unforeseen results one attempt to
eradicate fire ants in the southern us
killed wildlife indiscriminately but did
little to eliminate the ants in spite of
this and other mishaps the u.s.
department of agriculture and chemical
companies extolled the benefits of DDT
there was little regulation or public
awareness about its potential harm but
Carson showed how the overuse of
chemicals led to the evolution of
resistant species which in turn
encouraged the development of deadlier
chemicals
since DDT does not dissolve in water she
asserted that over time it would
accumulate in the environment the bodies
of insects the tissues and animals who
consumed those insects and eventually
humans she suggested that exposure to
DDT might alter the structure of genes
with unknown consequences for future
generations the response to Silent
Spring was explosive for many people the
book was a call to regulate substances
capable of catastrophic harm others
objected that Carson hadn't mentioned
DDT's role controlling the threat
insects posed to human health former
Secretary of Agriculture Ezra Taft
Benson demanded to know why a spinster
with no children was so concerned about
genetics and dismissed person as
probably a communist
a lawyer for a pesticide manufacturer
alluded to Carson and her supporters as
sinister influences aiming to paint
businesses as immoral in reality Carson
had focused on the dangers of chemicals
because they weren't widely understood
while the merits were well publicized
she rejected the prevailing belief that
humans should and could control nature
instead she challenged people to
cultivate maturity and mastery not of
nature but of ourselves Carson died of
cancer in 1964 only two years after the
publication of Silent Spring her work
galvanized a generation of environmental
activists in 1969 under pressure from
environmentalists Congress passed the
National Environmental Policy Act that
required federal agencies to evaluate
environmental impacts of their actions
to enforce the act President Richard
Nixon created the Environmental
Protection Agency and in 1972 the EPA
issued a partial ban on the use of DDT
long after her death Rachel Carson
continued to advocate for nature through
the lingering impact of her writing
taking a stand in the name of truth is
no easy task for another impressive tale
of strong conviction and good science
check out this video on Frances Kelsey a
pharmacologist who averted a national
catastrophe
[Music]